معنى من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكريه والاستراتيجيه اهلا بك لواء
دويري
مستمره في الشمال سوريا والعراق كذلك
برايك باي شكل وباي وتيره ستستمر هذه
العمليه
مستمره في قطار
الحمل الجويه والقصف المدعي ولكن القياده
السياسيه
ممثله بالرئيس التركي ووزير الدفاع تحدثوا
بصراحه وتحدث الرئيس اردوغان عن استخدام
الدبابات اي بمعنى اخر تنفيذ عمليه بريه
وان تم احاله الامر الى الخليه التخطيطيه
خليه للخليه الاستراتيجي
لتحديد الاطرش المكانيه لهذه العمليه بسبب
التهديدات المفروضه من خلال تواجد القوات
الاجنبيه سواء روسيه امريكيه بريطانيه
فرنسيه
وبالتالي اعتقد ان هناك يعكف على دراسه
هذا الخطه عاد الرئيس اردوغان وتحدث ان
العمليه سيتم شنها في الوقت المناسب بينما
بالامس واول امس كان لبعض يتوقع ان
العمليه سنه سيتم شنها خلال او هلال ايام
اذا هنا كان التخطيط لهذا العمليه يطبق
على نار هادئه ما لم يحدث امر مفاجئ ولكن
هناك اشارات من خلال الخطاب السياسي الى
نقاط الاهتمام ومعظمها سواء يعني اذا كان
تحدثنا عن غرب نهر الفرات هناك من همم
مطار من وهناك تل رفعه ومنبج اما اذا
تحدثنا عن شرق نهر الفرات فانا نتحدث عن
كوباني عن منطقه همم محيط العيسى عين عيسى
تل البيدر الى غير ذلك اذا هناك همم
اشارات عامه قد نستطيع استخلاص طبيعه
الاهداف التي يمكن ان تهاجم لانه اشارات
متكرره لكن دعيني اقول لا يزال التحديد
الامريكي التحديد الروسي وان كان ضبابيا
في هذه المره وغيره حاسما
الحان لتركيا ان تنفل عمليه بريه محدوده
ليس كما
يطمع الراي التركي همم دخول روسيا على
الخطوه محاوله موسكو اقناع انقرا بعدم خوض
معركه بريه برايك كيف سينكس على الارض
وكيف سترد تركيا في هذا المقطع
الاوراق التي بيد روسيا قويه للغايه لتفرد
على تركيا عدم القيام اذا ما قرار لماذا
لان ال- ال- ال- همم الوضع التركي الجيو
الاستراتيجي الان يعتبر في همم اجمل ايامي
لماذا الكل يحاول بناء الجسور مع تركيا من
اجل اجمل الاوكرانيه روسيا لا تستغني عن
تركيا امريكا
في الحفاظ على امنها القومي هذا الخطاب
السياسي عندما نترجم الى فعل على الارض
يعني ان هذه الجمل مفتوحه يعني تسمح لي
بشني عمليه عسكريه ولكن عمليه عسكريه
مؤثره وهنا انا قلت انها لا تنسجل الرعاه
الرئيس التركي الرئيس التركي في هذا اليوم
هذا الخطاب الذي عرضه قبل باحسان سنوات
تقريبا في عام 2015 و2016 عندما كان يتحدث
عن منطقه امنه بعمق 30 كيلو على طول 910
كلم هذا الامر قد يعني قد لا يوافق عليه
ولا يستطيع القيام به لماذا هناك اثباتات
العمليه التي كان من المحتمل ان تشن شرق
الفراق قبل الازمه الاوكرانيه تم ايقافها
لا بل العمليه العسكريه التي جرت وهي
عمليه همم نبع السلام لم تكتمل نبع السلام
كانت مخطط لها ان تصل الى المالكيه والى
ما بعد القامشلي الى نقطه التقاء الحدود
العراقيه الايرانيه التركيه لكنها توقفت
بعد انجاز 30% منها فقط وبالتالي بسبب
الضغوط وبالتالي الرئيس التركي يطمح الى
شيء وهو الحد الاقصى التحديدات المفروضه
عليه تحديدات مرنه تسمح له بت في عمليه
ضمن عطر جغرافيه محدده
دائما العمليه البريه لها حساباتها
المختلفه تماما عن عمليات القصف الجوي
والمدفعي على الارض ماذا تعني عمليه بريه
بالنسبه لتركيا
في بعض مناطق هي اقل من 20 كيلومتر وفي
بعض المناطق 30 كلم وفي بعضها اكثر من 30
كيلو متر على الخطوط السياسيه هذا هذا
يمتد تقريبا ياتي من جسر الشهور وياتي من
اللاذقيه ويصل الى القامشلي خط الام 4 وهو
خط معروف ومشهور وهو تقريبا الخط الذي يتم
دائما الحديث عنه انه هو الخط الفاصل هذا
يتم الحديث عنه في ادلب والان الموقف
الروسي له له علاقه همم موقع الخط الام 4
والقوات المنتشره على يمينه ويسارع لانه
طالب من سنوات باخلاء النقاط التركيه
ونقاط القوه الثوره من جنوب خط الانبار
كذلك خط الانثار له ارتباط قد لا يكون
مباشره مع اتفاقيه اذنا التي عقدت مع
الرئيس السابق حافظ الاسد حيث كان الحديث
يدور على 30 كلم يجب ان تكون منطقه امنه
لا يوجد بها ارهابيين او مناوين لتركيا
لهذا السبب تركيا ستعمل ضمن اطار اتفاقيه
اضنه وضمن اطار خطى الحد الاقصى خط الانف4
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي حدثنا من
عمان